Các bạn có một tiền của tế, tổng thống Mỹ đoan truang là tuyên bố Y-Ran phải bảo đam hạt động thông só tảyều biển hoặc muốn, trong vào mũi táng giờ,
nếu không sẽ phải đối mặt với các biển pháp quần sử, nằm vào hạt tầng nâng lượng.
Còn thế này, cho thấy là chương tứng sáng của Washington, chúng ta vào vệ tuyến vận tại chi lược tòn cơ,
phần nứng sâu tuyên bụng của Mỹ bộ tổng thông thông nư tất lực gần vũ trả Y-Ran tẩn báo,
nếu đối phân tấm thông hạt ở nẳng gọi gần, chúng ta sẽ nhóm vào toàn bộ hệ thống kịch lực,
không tìm liên làm các trường tâm công nghệ và nhà máy khu vối giòn Mỹ sử ủ trong khu vực.
Chúng khi đó theo hắn, ông, may gây điên,
yvram đánh đưa ra sống điều kiện trong hăng cầu để xuất chấm giữ suông độ,
thông qua các kênh trường sáng, các điều kiện bao gồm, yêu cầu vào đam không tài sĩnh chiến sự,
đấm cửa các cân cửa quân sự của Mỹ trong khu vực, bộ thường thị thải,
chăm rất cơ súng độ nguyên quan, thế là cơ trẻ pháp địa mới tại ở bên thông mốt,
và sự liết các bà nề truyền thông, mặt tay Rán cho là thủ định.
Fia y Rán khẩn định sẽ tưu cáo ở độ của sự,
cho đến khi đặt được buộc tiêu đề ra, đồng thời nhấn mạnh,
các bơ đi hiện nay nằm trong kế hoạch xa hạc,
giờ qua rất nhiều định tình hình lãng lâu tháng nhấn chống,
khi cả hai bên điều suy trị lập trường tử sáng cho vất cảnh suông độ tế bước sàng tổn thủ tư.